grèves reconductibles manifestation
cortège émaillées de violences donc je
le disais le climat social reste
extrêmement tendue
mais françois hollande reste ferme sur
la loi travail alors a t il raison de ne
pas céder sur après avoir déjà cédé
d'ailleurs puisqu'il évoque un texte
corrigé
il dit qu'il ya une négociation n'y a
pas une négociation puisqu'elle 49,3 et
que tous les français ont compris que
c'était un passage en force
mais si cette loi était utile à la
france aux entreprises aux salariés moi
je la voterai mais je voterai contre
cette loi qui est néfaste pour les
salariés et qui ne sera pas utile aux
entreprises
j'étais en haute-marne n'ya pas
longtemps mercredi et je rencontrais un
entrepreneur 20 salariés il faisait
cette fois c'est une catastrophe
elle va pas aider les pme elle va leur
compliquer la vie et en plus elle ne
récompense pas le travail pourquoi je
suis contre cette loi c'est qu'elle ne
récompense pas les travailleurs les
heures supplémentaires c'est à dire à un
salarié qui fait un effort
cette loi va baisser la rémunération des
heures supplémentaires d'accord dans
l'entreprise la wii tout masse par des
accords d'entreprise des référendums
sous l'égide de ces quarts mais ça sera
le bazar qui va être répandu dans toutes
les entreprises
et ça sera le nivellement par le bas
c'est une société low cost c'est eux le
renard dans le poulailler et ça va
favoriser ceux qui aligne par le bas au
lieu de favoriser ceux qui élèvent donc
france ô toi et de mauvaises françois
hollande a tort mais il a complètement
tort sur le fond et sur la forme dans
votre livre
nicolas dupont aignan voit la france
lève toi et marche vous dit que il ya
une préférence française française paris
européenne pour le chômage dans notre
pays alors vous réclamer des réformes
d'envergure et la forme du code du
travail en est une mais ce n'est pas une
réforme du code du travail la loi comme
vous je préconise une réforme
fondamentale qui est d'inciter à
produire français car la loi elle
conneries comme les réformes proposées
par les républicains
c'est la gestion de l'alignement des
salariés français sur le salarié roumain
c'est ça en fait
et bientôt sur le salarié chinois c'est
à dire qu'au lieu de se dire comme
va produire français comment on va
élever le niveau comment on va monter en
gamme
comment on va faire des efforts de
productivité eux ils ont abandonné et
donc ils disent faux précariser les
salariés comme les au 2e as et tous les
autres qui possède à la ligne de
bruxelles cette loi elle est imposée par
bruxelles
la réalité n'est imposée par bruxelles
ou par certaines réalités de notre pays
mais la réalité notre pays c'est
d'attirer de la richesse
si cette loi baisser les charges sur les
pme si cette loi eux supprimer les
travailleurs détachés c'est à dire le
régime fiscal et social qui favorise
l'embauché de travailleurs roumains
polonais espagnols qui ne payent pas les
charges sociales françaises c'est à dire
si cette loi elle s'attaquait à la
concurrence déloyale et qu'elle
favorisait les pme françaises mais je la
voterai mais cette loi révèle israël du
mois les travailleurs détachés nicolas
du poignet c'est là la france et engagez
vous le savez contre le système des
travailleurs des noms et qui aboutit à
du dumping social c'est vrai on le voit
la france n'est pas engagée de dans la
north france soutient les efforts de la
commission pour durcir ce régime
ça c'est du pipeau c'est du cinéma en
attendant il ya cinq cent mille
travailleurs détachés en france coût
horaire 14 euros charges comprises il ya
défend le court hormis ces problèmes le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya cinq
cent mille emplois volé ce sont des
voleurs d'emploi et eux avec la
complicité du gouvernement français qui
met la france dans la rue pour une loi
travail incompréhensible et au même
moment
il suffirait de dénoncer la directive
travailleurs détachés et d'obliger les
travailleurs détachés à payer les
charges sociales françaises du pays
d'accueil pour libérer cinq cent mille
emplois
françois hollande ce matin a lancé un ça
suffit à l'adresse des casseurs là vous
lui donner raison
quelle tartufferie qu'elle savait je
pense à molière les tartuffes ces gens
qui mettent de l'huile sur le feu qui
laisse les casseurs faire et qui après
fonde l'amalgamme entre la colère
sociale légitime et les casseurs moi je
suis ils ont jeté de l'huile sur le oui
quand on fait voter par le 49-3 une loi
qui est une loi de régression mais
profond d'accord mais la gare de 49,3 le
premier missile a rappelé c'est une loi
constitutionnelle être mais il ya des
usages vous savez quand on provoque les
gens quand on agresse un peuple en
gouvernant contre ses intérêts quand on
négocie un accord avec la turquie on en
reparlera violence et les gta non pas du
tout mais ce que je dis c'est qu'il ya
une colère sociale qu'il faut l'entendre
et en revanche j'aimerais que le
gouvernement soit plus ferme contre les
casseurs parce que le gouvernement est
faible avec les casseurs et dur avec les
salariés et ça c'est ce que j'appelle de
la manipulation n'a juste vous dites
vous dit le gouverneur gouvernement a
pris des mesures récemment est très
faible quelques mesures d'interdiction
manifester enfin rentrer de certains oui
mais la justice administrative a annulé
ses amis c'est la réaction que le
gouvernement qui est si prompt à
utiliser le 49-3 ne change pas un peu de
politique pénale
vous savez je crois que le premier
ministre joue la politique du pire
est ce que la police est faible avec les
casseurs boissons alcoolisées critiqué
par certains vous l'entendez un mollet
mixu lors de la police défend ce qu'elle
peut mais nous savons que c'est quand
même ce gouvernement qui a voté les lois
les plus laxistes en matière de sécurité
depuis quatre ans et donc c'est un peu
fort de café de venir maintenant dix ans
si vous êtes contre nous parce que c'est
sale
là j'étais à l'assemblée cet après midi
j'ai entendu monsieur valls c'est
extraordinaire en gros si vous nous
critiquez
si vous avez des paroles politiquement
dur
vous êtes un casseur la manip elle est
grosse comme une maison
y a pas un français qui va y croire ce
qu'il faut c'est deux choses est
beaucoup plus ferme vis-à-vis des
casseurs les interpeller les arrêter si
on n'avait pas voté les lois pénales
toby
ça irait beaucoup plus vite premier
point rien n'empêche de convives et
répète le ministre ayant rien il fait en
paroles rien n'interdit monsieur valls
de nous proposer une loi anti casseurs
je remarque c'est d'ailleurs la gauche
qui a annulé les loi anticasseurs
régulièrement donc que le gouvernement
propose une loi anti casseurs que le
gouvernement soit ferme contre la
chienlit n'est en revanche qu'on est
encore le droit en démocratie de
critiquer l'action du gouvernent et ce
que vous irez manifester avec les
policiers demain oui qu'est ce que vous
leur proposez vous concrètement le
problème des policiers il est double il
ya un problème de moyens mais le
gouvernement davant avait été pire et
c'est pourquoi je l'avais combattu sur
certains points mais il ya un problème
de respect est ce que je demande est là
c'est la mesure principale c'est que
toute agression contre un policier donne
lieu à de la prison ferme
je suis maire d'une ville de banlieue je
vais à peine tout langer peines
planchers la prison ferme deux policiers
gendarmes pompiers fondamentale deuxième
deuxième point que toutes les insultes
crachats insultes prise à partie donne
lieu à inscription sur le casier
judiciaire et non pas simplement rappel
à la loi
je demande parallèlement qu'il y ait une
présomption de légitime défense
notamment dans la police en faveur des
populations dans les cas les plus graves
c'est-à-dire hold up a marre mes actes
terroristes c'est à dire de permettre
aux policiers de réagir alors
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont complètement
bloqués il ya des aménagements comptées
à part et non c'est la première aménage
inistre citoyens qui avait le premier
aménagement mais qui est insuffisant
voilà ils ont une forme
d'irresponsabilité pénale pour les
policiers n'ont cessé l'idée que voulait
aller plus loin je veux aller sur un
point aujourd'hui
quant à policier est obligé de réagir et
qu'il y as doute il est dans une
procédure judiciaire qui va durer deux
ans où il est salie et il est lavé au
moment du procès je trouve que c'est
particulièrement injuste et tous les
policiers de france réclame une
présomption de légitime défense on va
vous dire c'est un gaming le tuer non
c'est une idée défendue par le front
national et par monsieur 6 juin et par
d'autres accords et je vois pas au nom
de quoi je la défendrai pas
ils vont mais fiona différent parce que
les vous essayez par exemple la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme j'en ai
rien à faire voilà il ya un maître je
n'ai qu'un m le peuple français
cette espèce de munich migratoires ou
l'europe l'europe pour moi c'est quelque
chose de bien c'est une civilisation et
la belle europe que vous avez l'europe
se couche devant un chef d'état qui lui
fait du chantage et menaces qui s'est
couché françois hollande et la maca qui
est allé discuter avec françois hollande
contrairement à ce qu'il a dit était
absent absent au sens et un la ville
hier et peut être qu'un déloyale
vis-à-vis d'un gala merkel vous l'avez
entendu anna mais il est le valais pour
le coup de madame merkel donc on connaît
mais le problème de fond c'est comment
peut-on accepter qu'un état voisin
important qui doit être un partenaire je
n'ai jamais été contre la turquie comme
partenaire j'ai toujours été hostile à
son entrée dans l'union européenne
mais comment peut-on accepter de
négocier avec quelqu'un qui vous menace
est ce que vous avez accepté dans votre
vie professionnelle de négocier avec un
pistolet sur la tempe
moi jamais on peut pas avoir confiance
dans la turquie pas dans la turquie
gouverné par monsieur erdogan et je pèse
mes mots qui a joué double jeu avec
l'état islamique
j'étais en polémique avec monsieur
moscovici sur une chaîne concurrente et
j'ai retrouvé l'article que j'ai pas pu
citer du guardian un article britannique
qui montre les liens de la famille de
monsieur erdogan avec l'état islamique
qui se sert du robinet des migrants pour
faire pression sur l'union européenne et
ce faisant a laissé des passeurs
exploiter la misère humaine et qui de
surcroît est en train de mettre en place
un régime antidémocratique
le pape qui dit de la france qu'elle
exagère la laïcité ressemble on en fait
trop mais écoutez le je respecte le pape
comme autorité religieuse mais je crois
que c'est l'honneur de la france est un
pays laïc et que c'est la condition pour
permettre aux français de vivre ensemble
quels que soient leurs religions
d'origine ou leur religion présente je
veux un petit peu plus loin dit si une
femme musulmane veut porter le voile
elle a totalement le droit de le faire
comme un catholique peut porter la croix
ça dépend où
voilà et des lois pour ça exactement
c'est pourquoi je propose avec mon
mouvement nous allons faire une
proposition de loi bientôt nous sommes
en train de la peaufiner qui sera quoi
qui sera l'interdiction du voile à
l'université à l'hôpital à l'école c'est
déjà fait et dans les services publics
et que les chefs d'entreprise et le
droit par un règlement intérieur de
l'internet est ce que vous faites cette
proposition est un taux elle va bientôt
sortir
je vous en donnerai la primeur dans le
pape est très explicite il est légitime
et juste après le modèle français
ce modèle républicain auquel je crois
c'est le seul modèle qui peut permettre
à des gens différents qui gardent leur
identité s'agit pas de le renier leur
identité de vivre ensemble dans la paix
et le respect est donc libre ou pape eu
de régner sur les consciences mais nous
avons une séparation que je rappelle qui
vaut autant pour l'islam que pour le
pack
j'ai lu justement ce que j'ai vu savoir
la presse alors je me suis précipitée
lire l'interview et j'ai compris que
nicolas sarkozy ne serait pas le
prochain président de la république
pourquoi parce que faut vraiment prendre
les français pour des imbéciles qu'ils
ne sont pas pour une raison très simple
c'est que comment imaginez-vous qu'au
nombre de pays schengen on puisse mettre
en place un gouvernement schengen
absurde ça voudrait dire que les
frontières sont gérés par des autorités
alors définitivement par la lame merkel
et ses copains ça voudra dire que nous
n'avons plus la maîtrise définitif de
nos frontières
et ça veut bien dire qu'en fait nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas changé qu'il est et
c'est son droit
profondément européiste qu'il abandonne
la nation qu'il ne veut pas que les
français contrôlent la refonte et vous
sortirez lui parce qu'il ya un problème
moi je ressemblais déjà bien évidemment
moi je suis claire je suis candidat car
je veux rendre la france à nos
concitoyens
je veux des frontières je veux que les
français soient maîtres de leur destin
ce qui n'interdit pas une politique
européenne et une politique africa com
vous voulez vous surpris de voir que pas
un mot sur l'afrique e66 n'ai pu voir le
doublement démographique est un mot sur
l'aide à l'afrique
on peut être ferme sur nos frontières
nationales
oui si parallèlement aussi on met en
place un vrai plan marshall pour
développer l'afrique car l'enjeu c'est
de stabiliser les populations africaines
et de leur donner une grille d analyse
qui a dû vous plaire dans cette
interview c'est important c'est sur le
référendum européen vous le souhaitez
bruno le maire également mais en somme
nicolas même résultat nicolas sarkozy
vous dit le référendum
ce n'est pas la meilleure façon de
répondre à une question si complexe est
gentiment vous dire en gros vous avez
tout faux il me fait penser à ces
avocats du suffrage censitaire et à ce
beau texte de victor hugo qui expliquait
justement que le peuple était tout à
fait capable de voter je le fais il a
violé la question avec une réponse
binaire
bien sûr et lui il a une réponse
complexe
bref la galerie en revanche la réponse a
été très binaire
quand il s'est agi de s'asseoir sur le
vote des français de 2005 tous ceux qui
m'écoutent savent que les français ont
voté non en 2005 et celui qui a trahi la
parole du peuple c'est nicolas sarkozy
avec le soutien des socialistes
ce qui est sûr c'est que système
bruxellois est une forme de nouvelles
occupations et que la démocratie est en
péril la démocratie est en péril en
europe
moi je pense qu une europe des nations
démocratiques qui récupèrent leur
souveraineté sur les points clés et des
projets en commun et c'est ce qui
différencie du front national je crois à
des projets européens comme airbus
nous croyons rêve européen non non ça
c'est un cauchemar
c'est je crois on l'a vu je crois à des
projets concrets tels que les
l'imaginait le général de gaulle et
konrad adenauer
c'est à dire la lutte contre le cancer
par exemple pourquoi pas un beau projet
européen à trois ou quatre pays le plan
de développement de l'afrique pourquoi
pas un beau projet européen l'union pour
la méditerranée avec les pays du maghreb
et du nord de la méditerranée c'est à
dire france espagne italie grèce
un beau projet quand on va sortir de ce
système binaire soit on accepte d'avaler
l'huile de foie de morue de bruxelles
c'est à dire un système de nivellement
par le bas et d'immigration massive
soit on est anti européen non
je vois le nombre de soutiens qui
commence à venir pour ma candidature et
je peux vous assurer qu'il ya des gens
de gauche comme de droite et ya même des
gens du front national qui nous
rejoignent et qui avait été vers marine
le pen et qui en reviennent donc je
pense qu'on est tout à fait capable de
bâtir cette alternative politique
monsieur chevénement ne parle pas de la
personne pour l'incarner j'imagine que
vous pensez que c'est vous qui avez
cette possibilité à moi de le décider
moi je suis candidat je présente dans
mon livre un projet pour la france qui
est un projet patriotique et républicain
qui est un projet pour revoir
complètement le fonctionnement de
l'europe sans abandonner des
coopérations avec nos voisins
c'est un projet sérieux c'est un projet
e solide et le projet et il faut le
régime politique et la machine polémique
vous avez dit arnaud montebourg à vous
rejoindre j'imagine que vous aimeriez
que jean pierre chevènement vous
rejoignent aussi sûr et puis henri
guaino et puis beaucoup d'autres je vais
vous dire une chose millions de da sur
le terrain il ya des mères qui était à
gauche à droite certains responsables
front national qui nous ont rejoints
pourquoi ils le font j'étais dans les
vosges le responsable du front national
des vosges nous a rejoints pourquoi at
il quitté un parti qui est à 30% des
voix
j'ai pas été le chercher il m'a rejoint
disant voilà je retrouve chez vous ce
que j'avais eue rpr il venait du rpr
j'ai cru que ça existe front national et
puis c'est un tel bazar je préfère venir
soutenir quelqu'un qui a un vrai projet
est une équipe dont on n'a pas à rougir
des élus terrain des responsables
associatifs des lanceurs dalet comme du
stéphanie gibeau eu des gens purs droit
cohérent et on va gagner à cause de ça
parce que eux
nous sommes des résistants nous sommes
des résistants et nous luttons c'est
vrai avec 1000 fois moins de moyens que
les autres mais nous allons gagner vous
pensez que le front national il fait
partie de cette espèce d'arc
souverainiste qui s'opposent à la la
construction actuelle beaucoup de gens
au sein du front national
on écoute et qu'elles font national
monsieur guillaume daudin vous le
connaissez bien je comprends puisque
bayonne direction marine le pen que vous
connaissez aussi donc c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça vous le savez
c'est le front national de jean marie le
pen c'est le front national de gollnisch
c'est le front national d'art nous tous
et le front national de filippo c'est le
front national e etc
vous le connaissez bien aussi eu bat
comme observateur je regarde comme sacré
bazar et vous en prenez une partie mais
voilà je prends tout ce qui vole
défendre un patriotisme républicain qui
redresse nos entreprises et qui
relocalisent un million d'emplois qui
rétablit la sécurité en mettant les
boyaux en prison qui apprend à lire et à
écrire à nos enfants qui remet l'hôpital
public sur les rails qui renégocie tous
les accords européens et qui rend à la
france le contrôle de ses frontières
et qu'est-ce qu'ils aident un programme
de salut public que je propose et je le
propose avec mon caractère mes soutiens
de dans un esprit de rassemblement
gaulliste